issues of the c-span update both for
just twenty four dollars
call now
[Music]
up next on book notes we discuss the
effect of generational trends on
american history and culture
our guests neil howe and william strauss
are the authors of generations the
history of america's future 1584-2069
[Music]
the authors sort americans into 18
generations they then distinguish among
idealist reactive civic and adaptive
groups and how these characteristics can
be used to explain history and to
predict cultural trends
neil howe and william strauss join us
now to explain their book and their
vision of the future
neil howe co-author of the new book
generations the history of america's
future 1584-2069
what's it all about
well uh generations is a whole new way
of looking at how the past shapes the
future
our book retells the entire story of
america from the perspective of separate
generations moving through time
we follow each of these generations from
childhood to old age starting with the
first puritan colonists and going
through the
small children of today and
along the way we discovered some
outstanding patterns patterns in history
that seem to be recurring in the
appearance of generations we found for
instance that
every generation belongs to one of four
life cycle types that seems to repeat in
the same order over time
the appearance of young war heroes is
almost always followed by the appearance
of a young generation that appears
indecisive and conformist to others
the appearance and history of passionate
young moralists is always followed by
a generation which appears wild and
uneducated
to to elders
so what we do is take these patterns and
try to use them to show america where
we're headed in the
in the future
william strauss co-author of the same
book where'd you get this idea
i wrote a book about 15 years ago called
chance and circumstance that was a
history of how the vietnam war affected
my generation which we call here the
boom generation
and back then
i was quite interested in how we were
growing up so unlike our parents
the late 1960s and early 70s were
in many respects a broad scale attack by
my generation against the institutions
built by what amounted to our parents
who had so indulgently raised us back in
the 1950s
and i was wondering had this ever
happened before in american history
and back in the early 80s when i was
working in the congress for senator
percy i was noticing the tremendous
harms that were happening to the next
generation of children how the how the
mantle of america's poorest generation
most poverty-prone generation passed
directly from a previous generation of
elders to a new batch of children
without ever touching any of the
generations in between i thought this
was a wrong of historic proportions and
i
uh again was curious whether something
like this had ever happened before in
american history
and as i
looked more closely at it and as neil
joined the project
about five years ago and the two of us
began working we discovered that yes
indeed this had happened before
that american society had had pulsed to
to rhythms both within the family and
within the world at large and that's how
our idea of writing the full story of
america around the 18 generations of our
history first came about how did you two
guys meet
well we met about
five years ago basically we were just
following the same interest in addition
to
bill's book about the vietnam generation
i had written a book with pete peterson
called on borrowed time basically about
how
how today's old age entitlements
programs may not be there for today's
younger generations when they retire
i became interested in
how we think about
allocating resources between the young
and the old why is it that some
generations when they reach old age are
rewarded for a lifetime of great
achievement and why is it that other
generations reach old age and they slip
into poverty and no one seems to care
about them
so i became interested too in looking at
patterns in the past and what was
remarkable is when bill and i
got around to
looking through history we found that
there were patterns that these things
rise up again in a predictable manner
where are you from where did you go to
school
uh california i went to school in the
bay area palo alto how did you get out
here in washington
well that's a long story
i first came out to
indianapolis indiana where i was a
managing editor of a magazine i went to
graduate school at yale in history and
economics i worked for about eight or
ten years as a policy analyst
i finally came down to washington and
continued writing and joined bill on
this project and uh before i ask bill
the same questions who's pete peterson
uh pete peterson is former secretary of
commerce former uh chairman of lehman
brothers [ __ ] loeb now chairman of the
blackstone group uh in new york you
mentioned senator percy earlier and
anybody that's watched this network has
seen your work with the capitol steps
what is the capital steps and how did
you get to senator percy's office
i like neil emma boomer who grew up in
in
1950s out in california and then went to
harvard in the late 60s in the middle of
that campus turmoil
graduated from law school and the
kennedy school there came to washington
worked in a variety of jobs in addition
to writing that book about the vietnam
war i started working with senator percy
right around the time elena newport and
i
formed the capitol steps along with jim
adala back in 1981
and over the past nine years
uh with elena i've written about 400
song parodies about
about the foibles of washington many of
them the same foibles that neil and i
write about in a very serious tone in
this particular book
and i i guess i'm one of those unusual
people in the entertainment industry who
after the show is over i'll go home and
and read emerson and steinbeck and
write notes about what happened in the
1870s rather than what some other people
in the business are known to do after
shows if someone has never seen the
capital steps
what would they see if they were and
where do you entertain well we have a
musical political satire show we perform
all across the country
we
do public shows here in washington dc at
chelsea's cabaret once a week on
saturdays
we do about 300 shows a year so
it used to be for fun one thing it used
to be
strictly for fun and for charities back
in 1985 after senator percy lost in 1984
we decided we would go pro and we now
are a professional troop do you have
nine record albums
you don't perform with the capitol steps
i don't perform no i don't think i dare
to
when i when i team with uh with neil i
try to be historical when i team with
elaine newport i try to get at least a
little bit hysterical
i want to show
our audience a chart that's in your book
and i don't know if we can get any
closer on it than we are right there but
you can see that
you have labeled generations
missionary means that you were what a
missionary is a peer of uh franklin
roosevelt these were the uh children who
were born in the exuberant well in the
in the aftermath of
of the civil war i would say that it was
a time when when the family was
was a warm place in american society it
was the first time christmas in the
modern sense was celebrated in america
with the jolly santa clause and
christmas cards and tree so you were
born between 1860 and 1882 well you'd be
over 109 right now and there are about a
thousand of you out there in america and
i hope at least some of them are
watching here today uh we remember them
mainly as the wise men of world war ii
the the elders who steered america
through a uh
the twin emergencies of the great
depression and world war ii neo how
about the lost generation well the lost
generation born between 1883 and 1900
was first noticed in america as the
exploited street urchins and newsies of
turn-of-the-century america these were
the
kids who suffered from the highest child
employment rates in american history
they came of age labeled as bad by older
generations who considered them a little
bit wild and uneducated
they were tired a bit by their by the by
the 1920s and some of the bad bad people
who came out of that decade
uh
and after the great depression
when they were the one age group in
midlife that never received any subsidy
from the government
they settled into a
rather reclusive old age but an old age
in which uh in the post-war america
they uh they re re-strengthened the
american family
they uh
increased their paid back the national
debt and uh and slowed slowed down the
the culture and gave generously to the
younger generations that came behind
them bill strauss what does gi stand for
well the gi generation
were the first gi joes as
the missionary general
marshall described them the best damn
kids in the world from world war ii and
we remember them swarming ashore on the
beaches at
iwo jima and
normandy
america first met them with charles
lindbergh and walt disney and the first
boy and girl scouts that america ever
had
these were team players and good kids
smart kids a little unlike the lost
generation bad kids of just a couple of
decades before
they they felt their
their major
brush with history and with heroism when
young and coming out of the war they
felt a huge generational slingshot which
energized them and the country they have
since then held the presidency of the
united states longer than any other
generation in our history from
presidents kennedy through bush and they
also upon entering elderhood found
themselves attacked by the boom
generation and have since then separated
into
into a senior citizen community we
never before used the term senior
citizen widely until we associated that
kind of busy optimistic
upbeat atmosphere with this generation
in elderhood of course
over the past two decades america has
funneled an enormous amount of resources
into healthcare and retirement subsidies
for this generation enormously beyond
what
what the lost generation knew and
far beyond what neil and i expect will
be available for other generations let
me just add here that an important theme
of our book is how certain personality
traits follow a generation from youth to
old age one of the characteristics of
the gi's back in the 1930s
and 1940s from somewhere over the
rainbow and accentuate the positive is
the is incredible confidence about the
future and a
a
a passion to be busy to be building and
to be constructive what about the silent
generation 1925 to 1942 that's when
people were born
the silent generation
were
were the ones who refined and added
nuance to what the gis were doing and
and they too felt the pressure of uh
of what the initials gi stand for which
is general issue the regularity of the
society they came of age
in a in a world that they felt was
overly conformist and set about on a
life mission of adding nuance and
complexity and other directedness and
cultural pluralism to a society that
when young felt over simple to them
they fused the white and afro-american
cultures to produce rock and roll they
were the leading early proponents of the
civil rights movements the non-violent
movements uh virtually all the prominent
uh african-american leaders of the civil
rights movement from the first children
who desert see who desegregated the
schools at little rock up through the
jesse jacksons and douglas wilders of
today have been members of the silent
generation but they had the misfortune
to reach midlife all the silent
generation did at a time when uh when
the uh
consciousness revolution of the 1960s
hit and this was when they were the
guardians of the family and it uh
splintered families on their watch and
it resulted in
[Music]
substantial weakening of the of the
protection afforded to the young
and then
in the past couple of decades we've seen
the silent generation be the dominant uh
decade in the co the dominant uh
generation in the congress uh this has
been a time when public confidence and
the ability of the congress to
to
actually solve the nation's problems has
eroded and they are zero for six and
runs for the presidency they could very
well be the first generation
never to elect a president neil boom
the boom generation now born 1943-1960
first arrived as the victory babies of
world war ii
they were also the first dr spock babies
who told parents to raise their children
a bit more indulgently with a bit more
relaxed style of nurture and give them
what they want materially so these kids
could think about deeper values and
deeper meaning
the boomers
the 40 the 43 cohort those born in 43 we
later met during the free speech
movement at berkeley in 1965 this was
the same college class they went on to
add passion and violence to the protest
movements of the 60s
during the 1970s
when everyone expected the boomers to
become a great new political force in
american politics
they instead entered a political
remission
by 1980 they had become the yuppie
and they they concentrated on a certain
cultural perfectionism rather than
rather than involving themselves with
politics they detach themselves from
institutional life from having families
from having steady jobs
today they're beginning to enter midlife
and they're beginning to show a
puritanical streak
the same generation that 20 years ago
trusted no one over 30 is today
beginning to police the morals of
everyone under 30. now this is a pattern
as with all these generations that we
see in every previous generation of this
type we expect to see a lot of more of
that sterner tone from the boomers as
they move into their 50s both of you are
boomers right that's right that's right
i was born in 1947 and neil in 1951. now
you see we define the boom generation
differently from demographers
you often hear reference to the years
1946 through 1964
as mapping the
baby boom
we think that's an interesting statement
about the fertility patterns of american
parents during that time but it doesn't
tell you about the personality of the
generation the most important thing to
look for in defining a generation is is
how the members of that generation
define themselves and if you ask people
who were born between 1943 and 45
whether they feel like boomers whether
they've always felt like it generally
they'll say absolutely
similarly you ask
members of what we call the 13th
generation born from 61 through 64
whether they are boomers and they say
please god help me no
and those uh you also refer to them as
13ers the 13th generation in american
history dating back to benjamin franklin
these are the 13th to know the american
nation and flag they also are faced with
a real hard luck life cycle reminiscent
of what the old lost generation knew the
number 13 is a good reflection of that
it's also a
slippery label something that the kids
themselves like because they're tired of
being
criticized by elders being told that
they're part of a of a bust a baby bust
group that is disappointing when
compared with the boom one thing one
thing we talk about with the 13th
generation is how
attitudes toward children changed very
dramatically in the early 1960s and
through the 1970s
the 13th generation are the first babies
people took pills not to have
and as the 1960s went on we saw a new
kind of movie come into
national popularity the rosemary's baby
the exorcist type film which depicted
the child as devil as bad mean and
selfish
many of the thirteeners today in their
late twenties remember that period and
their
sense of identity their sense of self
has in some ways been permanently shaped
by that today by contrast since the
early 1980s we've had a whole new
a whole new batch of cuddly baby movies
today
with the emergence of yet a new
generation
babies are to be protected we see baby
on board bumper stickers everywhere and
people think that children must be given
a better national mission and must be
given structure as children okay um and
we call them the millennial generation
the ones that will that were born in uh
between 1982 and in the year 2003. kids
who are presently in third grade and
younger that's when we saw a sudden
change in people's attitudes toward
divorce toward family towards a
structure and discipline in schools
a rethinking of many of the assumptions
and the educational experiments that
went wrong that many people in
retrospect believe went wrong during the
1970s
there is a available for anyone who
wants to read it and i'm going to bring
it up here
wide swings in the way people feel about
your book
as you well know from reviewers to the
jacket
one of the strongest statements made on
the jacket about this book comes from
senator albert gore jr before i read it
why senator gore
why did you pick him
he saw that he asked to see the uh an
early manuscript of the book a couple of
years ago and we passed it to him and he
uh
he felt that this book
told the story of history in a way that
people his age could connect with
how would like anything else that he had
encountered
i'm not sure this is an easy answer how
would he know for instance that you were
doing this book is this something that
everybody around town has known for a
while well because he appeared on stage
with the capitol steps and i chatted
with him about it
yeah he actually has a wonderful singing
voice too as well as being a good judge
of books well i bring him up because uh
his statement is very strong uh
generations this is the name of your
book is the most stimulating book on
american history i have ever read does
that surprise you
well it pleases us uh we hope it doesn't
surprise us too much we try to bring
history alive and tell it from the
from the vantage point that people
actually lived it most historians don't
tell history that way
he says as thomas kuhn predicted in the
structure of scientific revolutions who
was thomas [ __ ]
well he was a uh
an historian of
the history of science who wrote that
disciplines are periodically transformed
by sudden paradigm shifts for instance
when copernicus suggested that there's a
that explaining planets as revolving
around the sun could simplify and
improve
explanations of how the universe worked
let me finish that quote as thomas kuhn
predicted in the structure of scientific
revolutions all disciplines of learning
are periodically transformed by great
works of interpretation
capable of producing a paradigmatic
shift in thinking i think generations is
such a work in american history why all
of a sudden has the word paradigm become
so used in this town
well people are looking for a new way to
connect themselves to the larger story
of america that is the problem we felt
adrift over the past 10 years and we
think that the way history has been
presented
uh over the past couple of uh of decades
has been more in terms of the little
pieces and people are not as interested
in the little pieces now they're looking
for a unifying vision we haven't had
unifying visions of the story of america
for decades now and we're trying to
provide it in this book there's a
generational dimension to this i think
paradigm is especially popular word
among boomers like ourselves
what does it mean
it means a a single pattern which puts
all the pieces in the proper relation so
it's easily understandable we have a
theory here of a cyclical a a cyclical
pattern of child nurture and coming of
age experience which
explains we believe a lot about why
american history fluctuates back and
forth for instance between periods of
national emergency and periods of
spiritual awakening for example there
was another paradigm of american history
that people all remember from the 1890s
and that was frederick jackson turner's
frontier theory and that that at the
time was a simplifying point which
which uh
changed the way people viewed themselves
in their country they realized the
frontier was ending they were grappling
for something something that's new
and and if you're if you're talking
about a shift in thinking it's something
that perhaps could change the way
americans approach the future we talk
for example about endowments
there's been a lot of writing about
empowerment as
what some people say is the paradigm of
the bush administration i think we would
argue that empowerment is what people
were doing in the 1980s with the
self-immersion endowment is what we we
are more likely to be thinking about as
we move through the 1990s and beyond
when we focus on how we can contribute
to a better future for children about
whom the country is beginning to care
more on the back of the jacket you have
quotes from david stockman jody powell
lawrence mead william niskanen richard
neustadt father theodore hesberg marilyn
ferguson and cheryl russell
if my memory serves me properly they're
all over the lot politically did you do
that on purpose no that's just the way
this book is turning out we could have
added quotes by newt gingrich and pat
schroeder saying essentially the same
thing
al gore
is sending this book to every member of
congress he believes in it so much and
and
we're finding that it doesn't matter
whether you're democrat or republican
liberal or conservative there's plenty
in here that you that will please you
and some things that will displease you
our purpose is not
to advance any political agenda but to
get people to think more seriously about
themselves and how they fit into the
long story of america past present and
future
one of the first effects you had on me
was i noticed
that
the first pages you kept
mentioning homer
and i remember reading homer years and
years ago so i went out and got a copy
one of the most interesting things i
found is that uh it says on the back the
greatest tale of all time sells for 2.95
which isn't a bad deal let's see what
your book sells for today it sells for
22.95 yeah out of inflation there anyway
what i've got i want to ask you about
homer in a second sure i've also clipped
the uh washington post
uh
review
by
jay dolan you know it's actually the new
york times i'm sorry the new york times
do you know who jay dylan is well jay
dolan works uh or has worked for father
hesburgh uh
father hesburgh
thought our book was a monumental work
uh jay dolan is a professor of i think
catholic history and he thinks that
that you can't find a unifying vision in
american history and we just have a
disagreement with him what does it do to
you when you read in the new york times
as history generations does not make the
grade it pretends to offer a new
interpretation of the past but it is too
contrived to be taken seriously and as a
guide to the future it is about as
reliable as a neighborhood fortune
teller
well we we also notice in the review
that that he
is concerned about how we cannot define
a silent generation
uh that it's just too diverse he says
that there are there probably are
thousands even millions of people who do
not fit into the uh the pattern of
ambivalence that we identify within
generations we've never never tried to
say that that any
individual generation is going to be
monochromatic it'll obviously include
all kinds of people but as as you look
at at uh generations as social units we
consider it to be at least as powerful
and in our view far more powerful than
other social groupings such as economic
class race sex religion and political
parties which by the way takes us to
task for not talking about
class race sex and so forth which are
probably uh generalizations not not even
as effective as a generation to say
something about how people think and
behave
one of the things to understand is that
most historians never look at history in
terms of generations they prefer to tell
history as a seamless row of 55 year old
leaders who always tend to think and
behave the same way
but they don't and they never have
if you look at the way america's 55 year
old leaders were acting in the 1960s you
know the bullies and confidence of the
jfks and lbjs and hubert humphries and
compare them with today's leaders in
congress the indecision the
the lack of sure-footedness
um i think you you you'd have to agree
that 55-year-olds do not always act the
same way and you're dealing with
powerful generational forces at work
that explain why
one generation of war veterans war
heroes and another generation which came
of age in very different circumstances
tend to have different instincts about
acting in the world the kinds of
historians who are drawn to our book and
i'm sure it'll be very controversial
among among academics because we we are
presenting something that is so new
uh but the kinds who are drawn to it are
the ones who themselves have focused on
the human life cycle rather than just
the sequential series of events
some good examples of that are
our morton keller up at brandeis david
hackett fisher anthony
these are people who have noticed the
power
in
not just generations but the shifts that
have happened over time in the way
americans have treated children and
older people
and have tried to link that to the
broader currents of history in this uh
in this review uh he also levels some
charges
halfway through says when history does
not fit into their scheme they make
things up as they have done for on the
civil war epic according to their
formula the civil war cycle stretched
from 1820s to 1880s with only three
generations emerge in this cycle rather
than the four their theory requires why
because the civil war happened too soon
according to their calculations and in
order
for their version of history to come out
right in the 20th century the authors
are forced to argue that no generation
of civic minded people appeared in this
era
well he's right that we say that there
is only a three generation cycle in in
the civil war time and we explain in the
book why that is so
the cycle can be broken
that's the one thing that our history
shows us it was possible and it did
happen and it happened in the midst of
the greatest national tragedy uh in
american history and uh professor mead
at new york university told us he thinks
one of the strengths of our theory is
its resilience
and he cites the civil war anomaly as an
example of that
uh in that
it shows that if events go badly
and if there is a tragedy of that kind
of proportion that
yes it does have a deep effect upon the
way people behave in families and in
communities
and i would
i would say that as we look to the
future and we reflect on the possibility
that someday we might have a tragedy of
that proportion i don't think it's a
slide on our theory to say something
like that can cause this kind of problem
many historians have told us that if you
have 18 generations and you have a cycle
that seems to repeat itself perfectly
with that one aberration that the
aberration actually strengthens the
theory it means that you aren't simply
trying to fit everything into a
preconceived pattern it means that also
our theory is not deterministic that
there are ways in which
the the cycle can be broken or re-rooted
for a time and that's very important for
people to know that we're not
presenting here a clockwork universe
which no matter how we try or what we do
will always turn out the same cycle is
22 years well the cycle is actually i
mean four generations generations
average about 22 years but they range
from 17 to 33 years we let the
generations define themselves
and one of the things we've tried to do
with that chart that you're looking at
right now is is to show the total flow
of generational history in america and
how their life cycles have have evolved
over time i've done a lot of book notes
here and i've never seen anything quite
like this was this hard to do in book
publishing to get a chart that literally
flips out three pages worth actually
that was what the publisher was
initially interested in they saw our
early version of that chart and they
thought my goodness here is a brand new
way of looking at american history
how hard was this to do well we uh
we had to have an understanding of that
in our minds before we could write the
whole book it was the result of a lot of
thinking rethinking reading research
reconfirming some of the dividing lines
between generations looking at prominent
people born different years it was
really the the summation of most of the
research we did for the entire program
you see what this shows is what we call
the generational diagonal you see the
same event the civil war
hitting each of these four different
different generations at a different
phase of life
youth through
rising adulthood midlife to elderhood
the progressives as youth the gilded
generation
and rising adults abraham lincoln's
transcendental generation in midlife
and uh
henry clay and daniel webster's
compromise regeneration did you worry at
all about uh
you know there's just a lot of things in
this book and a lot of language a lot of
terms and all that did you worry that
there might be too much no we didn't
this book is not a light read
it it has aspects of it that are
challenging but what people have told us
is this book repays
the effort they put into it many people
have told us this is a book they go back
to again and again and that it's also
fun to read i think that the way we the
way we tell each generation as a life
story we start with their childhood and
we go to their old age and we try to
show the continuities and personality
and the way their
their minds develop and the way their
attitudes toward the world change this
is something that historians simply have
not done
i want to go back to homer
which i have not gotten through by the
way since i bought it trying to keep up
with this book's enough right here the
only reason i went out is you kept
mentioning and i went back and counted
you counted you mentioned homer on 12
different pages i think why what was it
about homer that did
well we looked at uh at people who had
glimpsed uh parts of this four-part
cycle before
and we went back through sociologists
and historical writers in the 19th
century
and we discovered that a few of them
some of them rather obscure like
giuseppe ferrari who's an obscure
italian historian actually had
described a four-part cycle that was
applicable in italian history over the
centuries
and actually going back to renaissance
times
and we went back and looked at important
pieces of literature including the uh
what
the old testament
and uh the the odyssey and the elliot
and looked at what others have said
about them and we discovered that even
some of the great seminal works of
literature and western civilization seem
to describe something that approaches a
four-part
cycle of generations it's interesting
for instance in the bible they often
talk about curses and sins lasting
through the fourth generation they
usually
don't say three and they never say five
we find that a four a
a cycle of four generations which
completes a period of empire building or
a period of spiritual prophecy until the
next prophecy or the next empire builder
arrives is a very common pattern used
long before we ever thought about
modernity and long before america was
founded now brian there's a reason for
the four generations too and one of the
reasons that uh
the book is is substantial 500 pages
long as it is is we we try to show not
just what the cycle is but why it is
and at the core of it is
is the very thing that traditional
historians overlook and that's the cycle
of nurture in families
we give as much importance to what
happens in childhood and in the coming
of age years as we do to what people do
when they are in their peak of political
power and when you look at the cycle of
nurture you see an ebb and flow between
overprotection of children which tends
to happen during times of spiritual
awakening
and
the
overprotection of children which happens
during a time of national crisis like
world war ii
through the late 60s and 70s we had a
period of under protection
and we're heading back towards a period
of of re-protection we expect that
that'll uh
if history is a guide reach a point of
overprotection in another 20 or 25 years
and what this what this does is it lines
up
with the same
patterns in history that other
historians have seen
about 80 or 90 years
since the very beginning of the story of
america we've seen great hinges in
history what we call crises that
that
reshape the the public world and roughly
halfway in between we have what are
commonly called by historians great
awakenings where a new values regime
comes in
it's happened ever since the puritans
first landed let me ask you a question
about that new york times review we've
seen lots of stories matter of fact i
think 60 minutes did a thing on frank
rich and his impact on broadway when he
he does a bad review some of those shows
closed do uh do you worry that the
review that you had in the new york
times will affect your book that way no
i don't not at all no because we find
with this book that the word of mouth is
is very important you have to read this
book and you have to read it carefully
to
understand
what our what our point is even among
the academic community which is
obviously always a concern of ours
because we
we do
present this as a legitimate
work of interest to historians
we've we've been gratified by the
response we get among many historians
who say uh it's it's about time that my
profession begins to look at the big
picture
some of the big picture books of the
past 30 or 40 years have not come from
universities whether you're talking
feminine mystique
or mega trends or future shock derek
bach as a matter of fact last year was
complaining how within the disciplines
of the social sciences at major
universities so few paradigmatic books
have emerged over the last half century
each of you
go back to where this all started where
did you get your first
interest in history
uh my interest in history probably goes
back to the time i was an undergraduate
in college
i was a typical boomer in that uh my gi
generation parents were all
uh interested in the physical sciences
they were very they were they were
educated materialists you might say that
out exploring the stars and quantifying
matter and as a typical boomer i grew up
interested in values i grew up
interested in how how culture develops
how civilization improves upon itself i
think many boomers were taught as kids
by their
war veteran parents that we sacrificed
so many of our years to build all this
for you but we're leaving it up to you
kids to find out where to take it to to
make the decisions between right and
wrong to figure out the right values so
this took me in the direction of history
and looking back to find out how people
in the past have figured out the
difference between right and wrong which
is a always an issue with the boom
generation what line of work are your
parents in
uh
the my father was a physicist and my
uncle was an astronomer my grandfather
also was an astronomer actually but uh
a family of scientists definitely i come
from could you point to anybody in your
family or in your teaching in your
school work that's that got you
interested directly in history did you
do it yourself
uh i did it myself again i think typical
of my generation i didn't i didn't
follow directly the footsteps of my
father i
chose a somewhat different path are you
surprised you ended up in washington dc
yeah that does surprise me and not that
i became an historian but that i'm here
why does it surprise you
it's a long ways away from california i
think many people out here don't realize
that
californians tend to stick to themselves
and they regard washington d.c as
three-quarters of the way to europe
is it a place you'll end up you think or
you go back to california well i've
lived on the east
coast here now for
nearly 20 years pretty soon it'll be
longer than i ever lived in california
so i think i've
made it my home
mr strauss can you tell us where it all
started with you
well i felt my first real brush with
history back when i was a high school
junior i was a page at the united states
supreme court
and that was the year that john kennedy
was assassinated
i remember sitting in the
judge's chambers i was with
justice brennan and justice goldberg and
justice white when the news came
and then within the next couple of days
i
i
watched on pennsylvania avenue as the
funeral
procession passed by and it caused me to
reflect a little bit on the fact that
this was the shining
night of my own parents generation and
through the
the rest of the 1960s while i was at
harvard the same
class that exploded in
riot and strikes although i didn't
participate in that i saw it and it
saddened me it
i was well aware of what my peers were
doing to attack the institutions of
their elders
then as i wrote
the book about how the vietnam war
affected my generation i i saw
really quite a tragic relationship
developing between what we call the gi
generation and the boomers and right
after that of course
the gi's separated into
into
their own culture basically abandoning
the culture for the boomers in return
for a substantial uh
reward in the form of entitlements
programs in return and it wasn't a very
happy been a happy ending to the
generation gap that we all remember
i think that that's how
i i came both to the question of
generations and to a way of looking at
american history a little bit
differently starting in families and and
looking at people moving through time
how did you get to the supreme court
page job in the first place well that
was a result of
the hard work of my gi
parents especially my mother who was a
very typical of the leave it to beaver
kind of
household that we saw in the 1950s a
mother who couldn't do enough for her
children
it was also typical of the kindnesses
that
that people showed towards children back
in those days i i certainly felt as i
was growing up that that the schooling
that people my age received was the most
important task that our community had
and i dare say in the decades since then
children haven't had that same attitude
what did your parents do for a living
well my father received his greatest
pleasure and triumph in world war ii
like many people in his generation and
my mother
like many women of her generation only
was able to discover relatively late in
life her abilities in the public world
and since then she's
become a
a masterful expert in public relations
out in san francisco and she's still
working hard
all right how did you both do that how
did you do this book
how did you physically
write 500 pages and split up the work
um well it was a it was a
a problem with logistics also a problem
with the calendar
bill and i often joke about how we're on
completely different sleep wake cycles
since he's a performer in the evening
and since i get up very early in the
morning our days overlap for about four
hours
but we worked with faxes constant car
transportation
on the phone daily
which is
quite quite something when you when you
have a project that goes on over a
number of years we were breaking new
ground in
a lot of areas that we have about
60 pages of very small type footnotes in
the back and we've we felt that
that we wanted to to give other people
a chance to carry on with this kind of
work there are many generations like the
gi generation of senior citizens nobody
has ever written a biography about this
generation before it's remarkable when
you consider their own strong connection
to history there have been dozens of
biographies of boomers
but and a few of the silent but none of
the gi's and none of the 13th generation
and
we had to sort through all of american
history and we found only the very very
isolated example of someone who had
taken a peer group from birth
and followed them all the way through
old age let me go back to the basics how
did you do
how did you do it in other words how did
you split it up well what we had to do
to write this book to write the history
of abraham lincoln's generation for
example you had to find a history of
childhood
and see what was going on around the
1800s and 1810s you had to find a
history of
of
youth or religion or or great
spiritual and abolitionist movements to
find out what young people were doing in
the 1830s you had to look at it at
histories of the family to find out what
people were doing and forming families
around the 1830s and 40s then then you'd
look at it at a traditional history book
to find out what they were doing at the
peak of power and then you would look at
histories of
old age to find out how they were
treated when old we had to to take all
of those pieces and write a completely
separate story to come back to this
whole question of reconstructing history
along what we call the generational
diagonal following the same group
through time you know you can read a lot
of
and some of them very fine books written
about the history of childhood and
they'll describe the street urchins of
the 1890s and then suddenly a couple
chapters later you'll get the boy scouts
of the 1920s
but of course these aren't the same
people these are different people what
we had to do was take the histories of
childhood the histories of adolescence
of marriage of old age and refit the
pieces together so that they're talking
about the same people over time and this
is really at the core of what the whole
purpose of this book is about again
though did you write one chapter and
bill write another we really both worked
on the whole book
we really did some of us would write
first drafts of different chapters like
i guess you could say i wrote more of
the first drafts of the of the 19th and
20th century century generations and
neil of the 17th and 18th generation but
we both worked on all of that by the
time we got to the end i don't think
you'll notice any stylistic gaps as you
read through did you ever disagree on
anything
not very much we worked it out well it
was a kind of a creative
process in which we would come across
something new and and we
always had to test it against our idea
of the theory and our own idea of the
theory of course evolved over time as we
saw what was actually happening out
there now for example in each of the
of the
chapters
uh that we have we divide the book into
really three parts one part to explain
what the generation is why it's
important and how it connects with
people in their daily lives
uh a second section in which we we and
it's the longest section in which we
tell the entire story of america as a
biography of 18 generations and we we
divide each of these
generations up into phases of life we
have a little section on their youth
coming of age rising adult midlife and
we deal with history always from the
prism of this life cycle
framework and it's important to say we
spend as much time on their childhood as
we spend on how they behaved as
presidents
bill strauss you said that you started
seven years ago and neil you joined him
five years ago when did you actually
start writing this book and when did you
finish it
well we
had to spend years doing research for it
collecting clippings about the modern
generations and
doing a tremendous amount of reading we
probably had
our houses are still littered with
hundreds of photocopies of articles uh
copies of books binders filled with
material because again piecing this
together along this diagonal was was
arduous work it required going through
many books just to get uh work out one
point of history did you computerize all
this of course
this book could not have been written
longhand i assure you
is there something the computer made
available today to be able to do this
you wouldn't have been able to do this
30 years ago well there's one very
important thing that the computer made
available and that's what we have in the
appendix and this is something that's uh
that's very new data
uh it's part of our second appendix
where we show the the
generation
the generational makeup of the national
leadership
uh by
year
and there are some startling things that
you discover in that for example if you
go to the next page over here you'll
find a
you'll find the largest generational
landslide in american history happened
in the years immediately following the
civil war when the the transcendental
generation which held the largest
generational plurality ever seen 90 of
all the
members of congress and senators and
governors were transcendental at the
outbreak of the civil war in
1869
there was a 19-point swing from abraham
lincoln's generation to ulysses grants
the biggest ever seen and it showed the
exhaustion that american society faced
basically voters were throwing out the
older reformers who had brought such
tragedy to the country and putting in
the younger pragmatists then when we
look at more modern generations we can
see
in
in our own time that the great 89th
congress what sometimes is called the
grandfather of entitlements programs was
right when the gi's were at the peak of
their power 75 percent approximately of
the members of congress and senate and
state houses were
were gis and they used that power
enormously to enact the great society
agenda the silent emerged into power
right around the time of
watergate and
the the ford and carter years right
around the time the country was
beginning to feel that it was spinning
its wheels and unable to solve problems
when you look at the boom generation you
can see that we're still at only 21
percent but we're at approximately the
same phase of life as
franklin roosevelt's missionary
generation was around 1910 and over the
decade that followed they swept into
office and with it they brought a a very
stern new morals regime to the country
and that's one of the things that we
predict that will happen in the 1990s
let me ask you uh
go back to you we talked about senator
gore earlier yeah he saw the book he
read it he gave you a tremendous uh
boost here on the on the flap let's say
he's thinking about running for
president and he picks up your book and
looks at it what does it tell him he's a
boomer he's a he is a boomer yes what
does it tell him about his possibility
of being elected president well
so far the silent generation has not
done a very good job of electing
presidents and we may very well go from
a gi to a boom whether it's democratic
or republican i don't know i guess i'm
in the silent generation if you're
between 48 and 65 you're in the silent
generation born between four no that's
no if you are age age i am i'm 49 yeah
and you you uh you were
you came of age just too late to
participate
as a hero in world war ii and just too
early to feel the heat of the vietnam
draft again go back to senator gore
because there i assume there are a
number of boomers that are out there we
don't have to use him necessarily by
name but senator kerry
i think
i i think whether it's going to tell
people of the boom generation who are in
politics or interested in entering
politics incidentally one of our
predictions is in the 1990s we're going
to see a lot of boomers coming into
politics from other professions other
walks of life the long-time incumbent
politician that is very characteristic
of the silent generation may become a
fading artifact and may we may begin to
have a swifter turnover in in
congressional seats
but what it's going to say is that among
his peers who are going to begin to
dominate the electorate in terms of
voting clout
are going to take a uh a sterner more
values oriented approach to the problems
of the country
this is everyone is already talking
about the 1990s as the decade of
austerity the decade of savings the
decade we have to sort of pay back for
some of the sins we've made in the 1970s
and 80s and a lot of this is boomer
driven we think we think this is
characteristic of this type of
generation moving into midlife
one of the targets uh uh uh
both intentionally and accidentally of
the of the morals campaign you might say
of the boomers will be younger people to
clean up the world or rectify the
mistakes of youth and of course this is
part of what we what we talk about in
creating this new safer more protected
nurture of the young millennial
generation yeah the other days tend to
look upon thirteeners as a as an army of
aging bart symptoms bart simpsons the
brat pack the kids who who uh
are a little too wild not well educated
and don't have that much to offer and
the kids who are now in their twenties
the thirteeners resent this as they try
to find their own way in a world that
they perceive is very difficult for them
in fact uh gore is a senator gore's wife
tipper gore is actively involved in in
the movement to
uh
to
to an extent clean up some of the some
of the lyrics and some of what's going
on in
in the youth culture and this is this is
an important boomers feel very strongly
about that because they felt to an
extent they were burned by that and they
feel the damage it can do to children in
a way that the silent generation who has
been running our culture
since the early 70s never felt that
damage because of course they had an
extremely conformist almost a smothering
childhood and they they have no
first-hand experience at what the the
danger of under protection can do to
children well we think that politicians
or marketers in particular product
salesmen who are concerned about how to
reach generations should think about as
they read our book
and try to decide how to either get
elected or launch a new product line is
look real hard at the section of our
book that will certainly be the most
controversial with historians
and that is
we have a whole section on the future a
50 page chapter on what we say the cycle
tells us about what the future will be
and in this chapter
is chapter 13 and
we call it completing the millennial
cycle and and what we do is not try to
predict specific events
but rather how the national mood will
shift and how each of today's
generations will behave as as they grow
a little bit older
and in the past what what people have
done is uh tended to assume that uh that
there won't be any any change in the way
older people will behave or that that 25
year olds will still be like 25 year
olds used to be and that has has not
happened in the past couple of decades
it's never happened in american history
today for example uh
if you were to
reflect on each phase of life
it's completely different from what it
was back in the nineteen sixties our
elders are busy and active and happy our
uh uh people in midlife are sensitive
compassionate caring concerned about
cultural pluralism the people in their
thirties the boomers are are
self-immersed and uh
and uninclined to follow the directions
set by other people very much unlike the
silent and in in the next 20 years or so
you're going to see changes just as
dramatic what's your biggest surprise as
you go around and do the shows what
questions are you asked that
or that you
don't expect or what are the ones you're
asked the most often
well one one thing that we've noticed as
we've talked to people is is the
different response that people give us
based upon what their generation is
we find for example that gi's today's
seniors are very history absorbed and
they they are quite concerned about
their place in history and so they're
interested in in this they also notice
that no one has ever written the
biography of their generation before and
they're interested in what we have to
say again gis are what age uh they're 66
on up born between 1901 and 1924 just
just to add to that
the way we tell the story of the gi
generation is we we explain what they
became as adults and in the 1950s and
60s by looking at how elders saw them as
children how special and good they saw
and deserving they saw them as children
and to a lot of gis today they
understand that that's a story that
makes sense to them and we also try to
show the gis and something that they
they really are drawn to that today's
little millennial children so far look
like a generation much like their own
and
most importantly that the boomer yuppies
that so many seniors today find
distasteful those cultural
perfectionists we all know about
are
very very similar in personality to the
gi's own parents the missionary
generation of franklin roosevelt the
problem was you see the gis never knew
them when they were young adults okay
i'm in the silent generation so what
kind of questions have i asked you that
would fit my generation well the silent
generation come much harder to the
notion that there is such a thing as a
generation because silent people tend
not to perceive themselves as much as
being part of a bona fide generation
they look at the powerful gis just older
and the
self-absorbed
boomers younger and they're more
inclined to say well everybody's people
and we're all diverse and we have to be
concerned about all these different
cultures and fragments of history we
also find just in general among the
silent generation a strong impulse
toward
towards making things complex they like
to see they don't like labels they don't
like generalizations this is part of
their whole life mission to take a
culture that was so simple and to break
it up to show how people are different
to show how people each have their own
tendencies their own desires and
basically to bring out the variety in
humanity this is what's made the silence
so effective in dealing with people i've
got to ask bill strauss as the leader of
the capitol steps when you go into
entertain a group
based on your
this book and your knowledge of history
can you tell in advance depending on
what age the audience is going to be
what they're going to their reaction is
going to be to some degree i can yes i
think all of today's generations have an
appreciation for humor which is a little
bit different i i will say one thing the
silent generation has produced the
greatest
ever american comedians and if you if
you trace
uh from the little rascals through
shirley temple to
jerry lewis stan freeburg
tom lehrer all the way up to
mark russell and many of the other
comedians of today they're born very
nearly at the same time what's your
favorite audience though when you when
you go out there i know it's hard to
label but
they're they're all good brian
you do have to have a sense of of who
your audience is but as long as you have
that sense and you know what they're
looking for they're all good
neil last question again any other
questions uh that you're surprised about
being asked as you go out and talk about
your book on the circuit
uh i think the what bill was talking
about the the generational division
among our response is uh
homers in particular the boomers
understand what a bona fide generation
is and they also are looking for
simplifying visions
very much unlike the silent
and they know that they're moving
somewhere beyond hippie and yuppie they
also are intrigued by the idea that they
are not the first generation of hippies
and yuppies you can look back at abraham
lincoln's transcendentals or franklin
roosevelt's missionaries and you see
much the same life path and they're
intrigued by the notion that when
they're old they'll become what we call
grey champions
time's up william strauss
neil howe co-authors of this book the
history of america's future
1584-2069 generations the name of the
book thank you both for joining us
thank you thank you brian
[Music]
join us next week on booknotes when we
discuss the riddle of power presidential
leadership from truman to bush a new
book by robert shogun national political
correspondent for the los angeles times
drawing on his 30 years of experience
covering campaigns mr shogun examines
the use of authority by the most recent
nine u.s presidents and discusses how
their use of power results in popular
success or political gridlock
if you would like a transcript of this
week's program send five dollars to tape
writer incorporated box 885 lincolnshire
illinois
zero six nine
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you